SETH VARGO: Hi, everyone,
and welcome to Secrets
in Serverless 2.0.
I'm Seth, and I'm a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
In the past, I've
spoke about strategies
for managing secrets in
serverless environments,
but a lot has
changed since then.
So let's dive right in.
If you've seen the earlier
versions of this session,
you're already familiar with
this application architecture,
but if you haven't let's
run through it very quickly.
Suppose we have a
web application that
tracks the number of
visitors via a hit counter,
like a 1990 style
website at its finest.
We only want to pay while
our site is being accessed,
so we're going to
leverage Google Cloud
Run and its ability to scale
to zero for this application.
But because our application
can scale up and down
we need to persist
our visitor counter
in some external persistent
data store, like Redis.
But our application needs to
authenticate and communicate
with Redis.
So that begs the question,
how do we securely
provide the Redis password to
our serverless application?
That's the journey that we'll
be going on together today.
We'll look at three unique
and independent approaches
to managing secrets in
serverless environments.
The first, is via plaintext
environment variables.
Then, encrypted
And then finally, with a
centralized secrets management
solution.
Let's jump right into the first.
Plaintext environment variables.
Plaintext environment
variables are, by far,
the simplest architecture.
We create a Redis
password, and we
deploy it directly into
our serverless application
by an environment variable.
Let's take a look at a
demo of how this works.
All right, let's take a
look at our first example.
We're going to
deploy an application
to Cloud Run that puts secrets
in environment variables,
in plaintext.
Let's take a look at
what this looks like.
What we're going to
do, is we're going
to look at our deployment
script, which I wrote to just
clean things up a little bit.
We're collecting the IP
address of our Redis instance,
and we're getting the Redis
password, again in plaintext.
Then we're going to build our
application as a container,
push it to a Docker registry,
and deploy it to Cloud Run.
And you'll also
notice that we're
using the Redis password
here, via an environment
variable to Cloud Run.
Let's go ahead and quit, and
let's deploy our application.
So what this is
going to do, is this
is going to build a container,
push a container to our Google
Container Registry,
and then it's
going to ask Cloud Run
to deploy that container
with those
environment variables.
Our application will read
those environment variables
at start time, and deploy them.
So we are pushing to
container registry now,
and then we're waiting
for our Cloud Run
to pull that image and
route traffic to it.
And when this is done,
we will get a URL
where we can visit our service.
Great.
So I'm going to go ahead and
open up this URL in a browser.
Great, here it is.
And as you can see, this
is a very basic website
that has a hit counter
that's backed by Redis.
Every time I visit the site,
I increase the hit counter.
I can reset the counter.
But what happens if
someone breaks the site?
So you'll notice the reset
counter method actually
includes the count
that I can set to,
and I can set this
to a negative number
and the site
continues to function.
But what happens if I set it
to something like a fruit?
Well then my whole
application crashes,
and we're presented this very
nice, helpful debugging page,
that's very similar
to what you would
see in like Rails, or Django,
or any popular web framework.
We get a bunch of information
about the request,
but we also get
the environment--
and you'll notice in this
environment our Redis host,
and our Redis password are
available in plaintext.
Anyone with access
to this application--
you can visit this URL
right now in your browser--
you would have access
to this Redis host,
and this Redis password.
Hopefully this makes it clear
why plaintext environment
variables aren't a great idea.
Great, let's jump back
over to the slides.
Hopefully that made it really
clear that you should not
store secrets in plaintext
environment variables,
not only do you open yourself
up to classifications
of vulnerabilities, it's
really not a best practice.
So that really only leaves
the other two options--
encrypted environment variables,
or a centralized secrets
management solution.
Let's take a look at encrypted
environment variables.
So instead of taking
our plaintext secret,
and putting it in an
environment variable,
we can instead encrypt
that secret first.
What that looks like,
is a human or a machine
takes the plaintext
secret, and they
give it to a key
management system,
like Google Cloud Camus.
Google Cloud Camus encrypts
that plaintext data,
and produces what we call cipher
text, or the encrypted secret.
We then provide this encrypted
secret as an environment
variable to our
application, this way
the environment variable
has an encrypted secret, not
a plaintext secret.
When our application boots it
communicates with Google Cloud
KMS to decrypt the value
and then get the plaintext,
but that plaintext
only exists in memory,
it doesn't exist
in the environment
given to the
serverless application.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at a demo.
Great.
Our second example is going
to leverage Google Cloud KMS
to encrypt the secret
value before we put it
in an environment variable,
then when our application boots,
it will decrypt the
value using Cloud KMS,
and only store the decrypted
secret in plaintext in memory.
So if someone gains
access to the application,
or the environment
of the application,
they would only see the cipher
text for the encrypted secret.
Let's take a look at
what that looks like.
The first thing
we have to do, is
we have to update our
application I've already
written some helper code
that makes this easy.
So we're going to leverage
this KMS decrypt method that
accepts the cipher text,
or the encrypted secret,
via the Redis pass
environment variable.
And then we actually have
to encrypt our secret,
so let's go ahead and do that.
We're going to run
encrypt string,
and this is going to encrypt
the string that we give it--
which in this example
is the Redis password--
with a Google Cloud KMS key.
I'm going to copy
this to my clipboard,
and then we also have to
update our deployment script,
because instead of passing
in the plaintext secret,
we now need to
pass in this cipher
text, or this encrypted secret.
Notice that we're
still passing in it
as an environment variable,
but we're passing it
in as the ciphertext.
Now let's go ahead and actually
deploy the application.
And again, this is going to
build and push our container,
and then we're going
to wait for Cloud Run
to deploy this new revision.
And then after the
revision is deployed,
the application should
behave exactly the same,
because we only decrypt
the secret at start time,
and we only eat the
additional cost of decrypting
that secret one time.
Let's go ahead and
jump back over.
So you'll notice that
the application is still
erroring, because we haven't
fixed the bad value in Redis,
but the Redis password
is now that ciphertext.
And because Google Cloud
Camus is guarded by IAM,
Identity and Access Management,
you cannot connect to this
Redis host using
this Redis password,
because you cannot decrypt
it, unless you have access
to the Cloud Camus KMS key.
Now this is great, but
there are some disadvantages
to this approach, which
we'll talk about in a second.
Great, let's jump back
over to the slides.
So as you can see, encrypted
environment variables
do protect against
the immediate threat,
and they're a great
starting point,
but there are some drawbacks.
The biggest of which, is once
you deploy your serverless
application with an
encrypted secret,
you lose centralized
auditing and visibility
into how that
secret's being used.
If that's a requirement for
your organization or security
practices, we need
to take a look
at the third option, which is a
centralized secrets management
solution.
In this model, the application
requests its secrets directly
from a secrets
management system.
So as a secret
admin or developer,
I put my secret into the
centralized storage system,
and as an application, I
request that secret directly
from the storage system.
That centralized
storage system is
responsible for encryption,
decryption, logging,
and monitoring,
all in one place.
On Google Cloud our first party
secrets management solution
is Secret Manager.
We aim to be that centralized
secret store that provides you
that value of auditing and
logging and visibility.
Google's Secrets Manager, is a
new fully managed GCP product
that provides a secure
and convenient method
for storing API key,
certificates, passwords,
and other sensitive
data that you
might need in your
applications and services.
Secrets rarely differ
across Cloud regions.
For example your
Twilio API key is
unlikely to change if you
move your app from US east one
to Europe west two.
For this reason, secret names
in Google Secret Manager
are project global resources.
The resource URI,
in this example,
refers to the secret named, my
secret, in the project named,
my project.
Even though that
secret name is global,
the underlying secret
payload, the actual API key,
is still stored regionally.
For example in
this slide you can
see that it's stored in US east
one, US west one, and Europe
north one.
But how does the secret data
end up in those regions?
Google Cloud handles it all.
We do this with
replication policies,
and we have two replication
policies for Google Secret
Manager.
For customers who don't
really have a preference where
their secret
payloads are stored,
you should choose an
automatic replication policy.
With this policy, there
is no configuration
and Google decides the best
place to put your secret.
But if you're a
customer that has
a requirement that your data
exists only in certain regions,
you should choose a user
managed replication policy,
and pick the specific region
or regions in which you
want the secret to be stored.
Regardless of which
policy you choose though,
Google Cloud handles
the replication
of that secret across all
of the selected regions.
You don't have to
run a Cloud Function,
or kick off a nightly cron job.
Google is the first
public Cloud provider
to offer a fully managed secret
replication across regions.
Now I have to admit,
I've been lying.
Up until this point I keep
talking about secrets,
but I'm actually talking
about secret versions.
That's because all secrets
and Secrets Manager
are versioned by
default. The secret
is actually just a
very thin wrapper
around a logical
collection of versions.
The secret version is
what actually stores
the payload data and state.
In your applications you can
pin to a specific version,
or you can use the
latest alias to pick up
the most recent highest
number numbered version.
Note, that latest
is a floating alias,
so if a newer
version is created,
latest automatically
points to that new version.
Seeker manager uses
an API for its design,
so that means that anything
you can do by clicking buttons
in the Cloud console,
or by running commands
in your terminal
via G Cloud, is also
possible in your favorite
programming language.
In fact, we have samples in
seven different languages that
allow you to call and execute
Secrets Manager directly
from your serverless
applications.
You can do so in Ruby, or
Python, Java, and .Net,
or PHP Go, and Node js.
Before moving on, you might
be a little bit confused
about Secret Manager
and key manager.
We talked earlier-- and the
second example we looked at--
leveraged Google Cloud KMS.
So what is the difference
between Google Cloud
KMS and Google Secret Manager?
Google Cloud KMS is a
cryptographic Oracle system,
nobody including
yourself or Google,
can extract the
keys in that system.
Google Cloud KMS
provides an API that
does high level operations,
like encrypt, decrypt, sign,
and verify using those keys.
Secrets Manager,
on the other hand,
is a data storage system
that saves, and allows
you to access secret material.
So while they both involve
encryption and decryption,
Secret Manager is more
of a storage solution,
whereas Cloud KMS is
more of a Crypto Oracle.
Let's take a look at the
different user journeys,
to help you understand the
difference between these two
products.
With Google Cloud KMS, in
order to persist a secret,
we have to create
an encryption key,
encrypt the secret
with that key,
and then store the resulting
ciphertext somewhere--
a file system, a
database, or in memory.
As we saw in the
second example, we
had to store it in an
environment variable.
Google Cloud KMS does not
store the secret, that's
your responsibility,
and it also doesn't
keep track of how the
secret is used after it's
been encrypted-- because
Google Cloud KMS is concerned
about the encryption keys,
not the actual data that's
encrypted or decrypted.
With Secret Manager, when you
persist a secret with Secret
Manager, you give it a
name like Twilio API Key,
and you give it the value
that you want to store.
Secret Manager handles the
encryption and decryption
automatically, as well
as the replication
across regions for ability.
When you want that secret
back with Google Cloud KMS,
you have to provide Google
Cloud KMS the cipher text,
and then Google Cloud KMS
will decrypt that cipher text
and return the plaintext
value, assuming
you have the proper
authorizations to do so.
To retrieve a secret
with Secret Manager,
you just access
the secret directly
by name-- example,
Twilio API Key.
If you're authorized
to access the secret,
Secret Manager will return
the secret and its metadata.
Let's go ahead and take a
look at using Google Secret
Manager in action.
Our third approach is to use
Google Cloud Secret Manager.
Unlike Google Cloud KMS,
Google's Secret Manager
actually stores the
secret material,
and you only need a
reference to retrieve it.
Let's take a look at
what this looks like.
Again, just like before, we
need to update our application.
So instead of pulling
the secret from KMS,
we're instead going to pull
the secret from Secret Manager,
using this access
secret function.
And like I said
before, this code is
all open source on
GitHub, and there'll
be a link in the slides,
and in the show notes,
so you could always
take a look later.
Let's go ahead and save this.
And now we need to
actually create the secret.
I've written a little script
called Create Secret that
just automates this for us.
You'll notice it
uses the G Cloud
command to create the secret.
The secret is named
My Secret, and it
has a value of super
secret, and then
we're granting IAM
permissions on the secret
to our Cloud run
service account,
because secrets are
denied by default,
so we have to grant access.
Let's go ahead and run
this command to go ahead
and create the
secret, and it looks
like it failed because
I already created it.
Let me fix that real fast.
This is why you
never do live demo,
something's always
bound to break.
So I'm just deleting that
in another tab over here.
Let's try that again, we'll go
ahead and create the secret.
And great it succeeded.
You'll also notice that it's
creating version one, that's
because Secret Manager secrets
are automatically versioned,
but we're just using the
latest here as one example.
And then lastly, we need to
update our deployment script.
So instead of having this big
long password from Cloud KMS,
we instead just pass
in the reference
to our secret,
which is My Secret.
We'll save this and
deploy the application.
This will need to
rebuild the container,
because we changed the code.
It'll push it to the
Container Registry,
and then it will
deploy it to Cloud Run,
and again it will use
the exact same URL,
just creating a new revision.
So we're just waiting for
traffic to route at this point.
Great, and it's done.
And if we jump back over to our
browser and refresh the page,
you'll notice that our Redis
password is still My Secret.
You'll notice that it's now
the reference to my secret,
instead of the
plaintext password.
And Secret Manager's guarded by
identity and access management,
so our application is retrieving
this value at boot time,
storing the plaintext
only in memory.
And even if this debug
page were to be presented
an attacker would not be able
to get this plaintext secret
because they don't have
access to Secret Manager.
And we can see that
the application
is totally functional.
Great, let's jump back
over to the slides.
So today's journey looked
at three distinct patterns.
Plaintext environment variables,
which no one is going to use,
encrypted environment
variables, and
a centralized secret
storage solution
with Google's Secret Manager.
In the past centralized
secrets management
have required
upfront and continued
operational investment.
With Google's
Secret Manager, you
have a fully managed
secrets management solution
right on Google Cloud.
We're also expanding
integrations with other Google
Cloud products.
In the future, you
won't even have
to do this environment variable
dance with Cloud Run or Cloud
Functions or other
Google Cloud products,
because we'll have first
party integrations to directly
retrieve your secret at runtime.
Now, if you come to earlier
versions of this talk
you might be familiar
with Berglas.
If you're not familiar,
Berglas is an open source tool
for doing secret management
on Google Cloud--
it predates Secret
Manager and it largely
influenced the design
of the first party
product we have today.
Berglas is a fully interoperable
solution with Google Secret
Manager, we actually designed
it that way from the onset.
If you're already using Berglas
for your serverless secrets,
migrating Secret
Manager is super easy.
There is a new built in command
in Berglas, Berglas Migrate,
that takes the name
of the storage bucket
where your secrets are stored,
and automatically migrates
those from Google Cloud
Storage to Secret Manager,
keeping their existing
names and permissions.
Then, in your application,
simply change the Berglas
reference to the SM reference--
which is short for Secret
Manager--
and redeploy your application.
That's actually it.
Berglas is completely
interoperable with Secret
Manager, and you don't have to
change your workflow to use it.
Best of all, you
can mix and match.
You can have some secrets
that come from Berglas,
and some secrets that
come from Secret Manager,
all using the same unified API.
Thank you so much for
coming on this second Secret
in Serverless journey with me.
Hopefully we've made it
clear, the different secrets
management solutions
on Google Cloud,
and how you can best
secure your serverless
secrets in your
serverless applications.